PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE AND TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. YOUR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HAVE
ACCESS OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY
THIS HEARING WILL BE STREAMED ON
THE ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE IN
MATTERS OF THE POOR I CAN
PROVIDE TESTING. PERSON HERE.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN MY FAVORITE
ROOM IN THE CAPITOL OR VIA THE
PHONE. FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM WE ARE REQUIRING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEING. WHICH LOOKS
LIKE SOUTHWEST AIR. PLEASE
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF OUR
SERGEANTS AND POSTED GUIDANCE IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL OR THE NATIONAL ITEM I WILL
ASK YOU TO A WHICH THE- PHONE
THE APPROACH TIME. REMEMBER OF
THE- WILL BE PROVIDING AN THE
TELEPHONE WE ARE YOU A MOD
TELEPHONE DEVICE THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HERE IS. SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE- TWO EIGHT NINE
OR FIVE SEVEN ANDTHE PIN NUMBER
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN. SO THE TO THE CURRENT
DEBATE. I DID THE ORIGINAL
NUMBER IN MILITARY LET ME GO
CIVILIAN I USED TO CALL IN
AIRSTRIKES- NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 NOW. OUR ESTEEMED
CHAIR WHO IS SMARTER THAN I AM
WILL TAKE OVER. YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB THANK YOU MISPLACED
YOUR MISTER VICE CHAIR- I'M JUST
GONNA- ASK THAT ARE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- COME TO THE HEARING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO THAT. WE
ONLY HAVE FOUR CONSENT I SENT
THOSE THAT I'M GONNA BE HAPPY TO
START PRESENTING RIGHT NOW.
WITHOUT CAR- MOTHER ME BE A
WEIGHT- CAN AND- BEING AS SOON
AS THEY GET HERE ONCE THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE DONE A COUPLE
OF. A COUPLE ITEMS I JUST WANT
TO GO OVER THE VIA THE VICE
CHAIR ALREADY WENT THROUGH THE
NUMBERS FOR CALLING PURPOSES.
YOU FOR CALLING PURPOSES THE
NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE
PIN NUMBER IS. THREE I'VE. ONE
TWO SEVEN- PLEASE CALL IN WHEN
YOU HEAR THE AUTHOR OF STARTING
THEIR PRESENTATION AND IN THIS
CASE THERE'S ONLY GONNA BE ONE
AUTHOR MAKING TO PRESENTATION-
AND IF YOU ARE CALLING IT NAY
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES THEIR LIVES IN BY S.
YOUR DEVICE. WITH HE'S A AND IF
YOU HAVE A QUESTIONS PLEASE HAS
CONTACT MY OFFICE AT
916-319-2046 AGAIN LET ME REPEAT
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS FOR ANYONE
LISTENING IN THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS IS EIGHT SEVEN. TO AND
THE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE
TWO SEVEN AND IF YOU COULD HAVE
ARE HAVING A TOUGH TIME GETTING
THROUGH CALL MY OFFICE AT SIX
ONE NINE TWO. SIX OF B. YOU
START THE HEARING I WANT LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT THE- VACANCY
FOR TODAY IS BEING FILLED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. AND
THERE ARE GOING TO BE FOR BILLS
ON CONSENT A. B. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY ONE. TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FIVE SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FIVE AND RIGHT
NOW I AM TO BE PRESENT TO BE.
STARTING TWENTY FORTY SEVEN AND
THEN GOING ON TO TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX AND I'M GONNA ASK A
MISTER VICE CHAIR. TO OVERSEE
THIS THE HEARING AGAIN.
THE.
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NEWS ARIAN HERE TO PRESENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AND THEN SIX.
MISTER AZARIAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF VICE CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR- AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN CREATES THE HOUSING
STABILIZATION TO PREVENT AND END
HOMELESSNESS AMONG ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THIS
BILL THE WITH. WE HELPING IN A
COMPETE DEVELOPING COMMITTEE ON
APRIL TH. PAST WITH A FIVE TO
ONE VOTE AND THE HOUSING CHAIR
HAS COME ON AS A JOINT AUTHORS
MOVING FORWARD. WE KNOW OLDER
LOW INCOME QUALIFY. THE BILITY
SCAN BEFORE THEIR AND ARE FACING
A SURGE IN HOMELESSNESS THIS
LEGISLATION FURTHERS THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING GOAL OF
PREVENTING HOMELESSNESS AMONG
OLDER ADULTS. THIS LEGISLATION
IS VALUES DRIVEN AND REQUIRES A-
TEN VISION HOUSING AS A
COMPONENT OF HEALTHY LIVING AS
WE AGE. TO HELP GRASP THE NEED I
WANT TO SHARE SOME VERY SIMPLE
STATISTICS ABOUT RENT AND INCOME
FAIR MARKET RENT IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS HUD'S ESTIMATE OF
MEDIAN RENTS. FOR NON LUXURY
APARTMENT INCREASED A HUNDRED
AND 16% SINCE TWO THOUSAND. FROM
SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND TWO.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION TO TWENTY TWENTY
DOLLARS MEDIAN RENTS STILL
INCREASED 35% FROM TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY TWENTY. UP FROM TWO
THOUSAND TO TWENTY TWENTY DURING
THE SAME TIME MEDIAN RENTER
HOUSEHOLD INCOME ONLY INCREASED
BY 6% CALIFORNIA RENTERS MUST
EARN AN AVERAGE OF THIRTY NINE
DOLLARS AN HOUR TO FOR THE
AVERAGE TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT
THE I JUST NEED SOME HELP H. THE
NATION. IN LOSS IN COUNTY
INCREASED C. FROM TWO THOUSAND
TEN TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. S.
S. SEVEN HUNDRED TWELVE DOLLARS
A MONTH IN TWENTY TWENTY. TWO
THOUSAND FORTY DOLLARS A MONTH
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS THE
MAXIMUM GRANT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
AND FROM TWELVE SIXTY FIVE A
MONTH IN TWO THOUSAND TO
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS
THE MAXIMUM GRANT. PER COUPLE
PER MONTH SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
THE SSI GRANT AMOUNT HAS
INCREASED BY AN AVERAGE AMOUNT
OF ONE POINT 2% ANNUALLY. A
COMPARING SSI INCREASES WITH
RENT INCREASES WITHOUT ADJUSTING
FOR INFLATION RENT INCREASED
ABOUT 48% FASTER THAN SS SIGHING
. LISTEN AND TWENTY TWENTY AN
ENTIRE SSI CHECK WAS LESS THAN
THE MEDIAN COST OF RENT IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE PAST TWO
DECADES THIS CRISIS HAS BEEN
GROWING WITH ME REPRESENTING A
PORTION OF THE COALITION BEHIND
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN- IS
YES MAIN- PUBLIC THE PAYLOAD
WITH THE JUSTICE IN AGING. WAIT. TEACHER. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YES MEAN
PALETTE ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE
MAGING PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB
TWO FIVE FOUR SEVEN JUSTICE IN
AGING IS A NATIONAL LEGAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO ENDING
SENIOR POVERTY AND ADVANCING
EQUITY FOR OLDER ADULTS WE
APPRECIATE THE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND ESPECIALLY
THE CHAIRS ALL OF THIS IMPORTANT
GOAL CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING
. EIGHT OUT OF TEN EXTRA. INCOME
OLDER RENTERS ARE PAYING MORE
THAN HALF OF THEIR INCOME FOR
RENT LEAVING THEM VULNERABLE TO
EVICTION AND HOMELESSNESS.
CALIFORNIANS AGE FIFTY AND OLDER
ARE THE FASTEST GROWING AGE
GROUP EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
NOW COMPRISING 45% OF
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. AND THERE ARE STARK
RACIAL DISPARITIES WITH BLACK
OLDER ADULTS TIME AT A FIVE
TIMES GREATER RISK. WHAT'S THAT
ARE WHITE PART. AB TWO FOUR
SEVEN THE HOW STABILIZATION ACT
ADVANCES A KEY GOAL OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING TO PREVENT
AND OLDER ADULTS AND DISABLED
ADULT HOMELESSNESS. THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A MULTI YEAR RUN
STABILIZATION FUND TO PROVIDE
RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO THIS
POPULATION WHO ARE AT IMMINENT
RISK OF HOMELESSNESS OR
CURRENTLY ON HOUSE. STUDY SHOW
THAT HOUSING SUBSIDIES ARE
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS THIS FUND WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
OF AGING WHICH TO COME. TO WHAT
THIRTY. THERE PROGRAMS AND CAN
BE BASED OR- WE ESTIMATED THIS
PROGRAM WOULD ENABLE TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS ANNUALLY TO ACCESS OR
THANK. SEVEN AND PEOPLE
RECEIVING SUBSIDIES THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM WILL BE LINKED TO AND
PRIORITIZED FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED
HOUSING SUBSIDIES THANK YOU AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHARON
REPORT AND I'M WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WHERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN. I'D LIKE TO SHARE THE
STORY OF WALLACE RICHARDS AND
WELLS BECAME HOMELESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME AT AGE FIFTY SEVEN HE
HAD LIVED IN CALIFORNIA ALMOST
HIS ENTIRE LIFE AND IT ENDED
HOUSE L.
WHEN HIS FATHER PASSED AWAY HIS
LINK TO MANY OF HIS CONSTRUCTION
JOBS WITH. AT THE SAME TIME HIS
WIFE OF TWENTY YEARS ASKED FOR A
DIVORCE AND SHE ENDED UP KEEPING
HOUSE AND HE MOVED IN WITH HIS
MOTHER. WHEN HIS MOTHER DIED
SUDDENLY HE REALIZED HE COULDN'T
KEEP PAYING THE RENT ON THEIR
HOUSE AND HAD TO MOVE INTO THIS
TRACK. HE SAID FIFTY SEVEN OLD I
WAS HOMELESS AND FOR THE NEXT
YEAR AND A HALF ALL SIX FEET TWO
INCHES OF ME SLEPT IN THE FIVE
FOOT CAB OF MY TRUCK. IT WAS
MISERABLE. I SUFFER THE
HUMILIATION OF HAVING TO RELIEVE
MYSELF IN THE ALLEY. AND HAVING
TO PUT TO. TRACK WHEN IS TO GET
. HE I KEPT MYSELF CLEAN AND FED
AS BEST I COULD BUT I WAS
DEPRESSED AND LOST I WAS REALLY
DRAFTING TRUST ME UNTIL YOU'VE
BEEN THERE UNTIL YOU'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN HOMELESS YOU CANNOT BEGIN
TO IMAGINE WHAT THIS IS LIKE I
WAS LUCKY BECAUSE AT LEAST I HAD
THE SHELTER OF MY TRUCK SO MANY
OTHERS I ENCOUNTERED HAD ONLY
THE HARD COLD CEMENT. TO GREET
THEM AT NIGHT. WALLACE WAS ABLE
TO ACCESS THE HOTEL ROOM THROUGH
PROJECT ROOM KEY TEMPORARILY BUT
THEN HAD TO MOVE OUT AND AGAIN
ENDED UP IN HIS TRUCK.
EVENTUALLY HE MADE A CASE
MANAGER WHO HELPED HIM. ACCESS A
HOUSING SUBSIDY AN APARTMENT IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING WHERE HE'S
LIVED FOR TWO YEARS. WELL AS
SAID NOW I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN
GIVEN A SECOND CHANCE AND I'M
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL
THE SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE TO ME. I'M LEARNING
KEYBOARDING AND COMPUTING AND
HOPE TO EARN A BACHELOR OF
SCIENCE DEGREE. I'M MAKING
SOMETHING OF MYSELF AND I WANT
TO GET BACK. WELL THIS
RICHARDSON IS ONE OF THE
THOUSANDS WHO HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM HOUSING SUBSIDIES. BUT HE
ADMITS HE WAS A LUCKY ONE. SO
MANY OTHER OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
STILL LIVING IN THEIR CARS
TRUCKS OR THAT COLD HARD CEMENT
TO GREET THEM AT NIGHT THAT
WHILE THIS TALKED ABOUT. HOUSING
SUBSIDIES HAVE REDUCED
HOMELESSNESS AMONG VETERANS BY
OVER 40% NATIONWIDE AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT WOULD
SIMILARLY HELP TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
GET INTO DECENT SAFE HOME TO LAY
THEIR HEADS AT NIGHT. I URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TO PASS A PIECE
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL SUPPORT NEW
HEARING ROOM. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS A STRATEGY
THREE SIXTY HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO HOUSING
COMMISSION SPORTIVE APOLOGIES TO
THE COMMITTEE WE GOT IN LATE BUT
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
SUPPLEMENT. THANK YOU. CRITICAL
ACOSTA THE STATE COUNCIL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU. JOSH DUGGAR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK AND
CENTER FOR ELDERS INDEPENDENCE
SUPPORT. VERY WELL. SO JUST A
SLIGHT PAUSE DO WE HAVE A QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE QUORUM. THANK
YOU. SAYS ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH
A QUORUM NAZARIAN. THE PAL YOU.
BOERNER HORVATH. REYES YEAH
BEFORE THANK RUBIO HERE. YOUR
WAS WHOLESALER MUSTER IN. YEAH
THERE VERY WELL. ETIENNE'S T.
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE PEOPLE OF SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO AS A TEST TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT IF YOU CAN. HAVE NOT
DONE SO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WE'RE GONNA GO. TO NINE
SEVEN. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LINE FIFTY EIGHT. AFTERNOON
CHAPARRAL ON BEHALF OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY.
TWO FIVE FOUR SEVEN. LINE FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BENEFITED CANNOT BACK
BOOK HELPED SHAPE THE STATE
MIGHT ASSOCIATION THE PROGRAM OF
ALL INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE
ELDERLY AND SUPPORT. BLIND THE.
THREE NANCY GOLDBERG FROM JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICE OF LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN. LINE SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS IS YOUR REMEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT
DIVISION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FOR THIS
VULNERABLE POPULATION THANK YOU
. LINE. SEVENTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF KETV SPONSOR LEADING
H. CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS AFTER
CON LET THE SENIOR COMMUNITY
LIKE STAFF HOUSING RETIREMENT.
AND CLARA METHOD RETIREMENT
FUNDING. THANK PAUL YOUR SERVICE
. HELLO WHO AND THE VALLEY
VILLAGE RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. LINE. SIXTY SIX. MY
NAME IS JACK THIRTY YEAR
ADVOCATES AND JUST MAKING THE
POINT IN TIME COUNT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. LINE
EIGHTY. YES MY NAME IS MELANIE
TAYLOR STARK A DISTRICT FORTY
ONE AND I SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN. LINE. SEVENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DAN OPEN FIRST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
SUPPORT. LINE. SEVENTY SIX. HI
MY NAME IS WHEN I BLACKWELL AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN. ONE. HELLO YEAH SURE NOT
ALONE- ARE GOOD ACTORS MY NAME
IS DANNY A STRONGER OF ALL HERE
FOR A. R. P. CALIFORNIA SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF OUR THREE POINT
THREE MILLION A ARE KEY MEMBERS
AND ALL OLDER CALIFORNIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. BY
SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS GEORGIA SO WITH
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE AM. LINE SIXTY ONE. HI THIS
IS ALLEY CANNING TEN WITH THE
COUNTY AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU BYE BYE SEVENTY
. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY BURNS
WITH BOTH SO COMPELLING
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER IN SAN
JOSE AND THE AGENTS OR
COLLABORATIVE THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. ARE CALLING AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. WHY. SEVENTY
EIGHT. BY SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WILLIAM MOVE
ON TO LINE EIGHTY TWO. HI THIS
IS THE ABA CARILLO ON BEHALF OF
THE UNITED WAY OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN AND AMPLE SUPPORT. AND
REYES AND JONAH IS THE FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WHO HAS NOT SPOKEN SO FAR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. VERY WELL ARE
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. A. T. T. OPERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE SEVERAL PEOPLE OF SIGNAL BUT
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE EIGHTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON CAROLINE
FRANK GEHRY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES WERE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
BLIND AB ONE. THIS IS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING AND WE ARE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
LINE SIXTY. HI MY NAME IS NANCY
STEVENS ON A RESIDENTS IN A LONG
TERM CARE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY NINE. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
MIND IS NOW OPEN. AND WE'RE
GONNA TRY A LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
AGAIN ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK VERY WELL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANYONE HAVE
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY I HAVE SOME SHORT
COMMENTS. BY WILL ABSTAIN ON HIS
BILL. AND HERE'S WHY I'M NOT
AGAINST IT. WE'RE DOING THE BEST
WE CAN DO. THE CHAIR AND I HAVE
WORKED FOR YEARS TOGETHER-
BASICALLY. SPITTING INTO THE
WIND. BECAUSE THE BABY BOOMERS
IS A TSUNAMI. AND MANY IS OF THE
BABY BOOMERS THAT DIDN'T MAKE
MONEY THAT THAT WORKED OUR WHOLE
LIVES MINIMUM WAGE THEY'RE IN
DEEP TROUBLE THE AVERAGE SOCIAL
SECURITY CHECK IS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS
YOU CAN'T RENT TO CHECK FOR THAT
REALLY. AND THE MINIMUM IS NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS A
MONTH. IN THE MINIMUM MINIMUM-
IN OTHER WORDS PEOPLE THAT ARE
BASICALLY HOMELESS. SIX HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE LIVING ON
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE HOMELESS SO.
I'M NOT CRITICIZING THIS BILL IN
ANY WAY WE'RE WE'RE GOOD. BUT
WE'VE SPENT SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS ON HOMELESSNESS OF FOR
THE AGED WHICH I QUALIFY FOR THE
AGED PART. I'M M. ONE OF MY
CONCERNS IS ARE WE GET IN OUR
BANG FOR THE BUCK. PROBABLY WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT- A BILL IN
THE FUTURE THAT EITHER THE CHAIR
OR YOU ALL SHOULD BRING FORWARD
WOULD BE LOOKING AT REFORMS. FOR
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW. AND
THAT COULD GO THROUGH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THEY COULD GO THROUGH
THE AUDIT COMMITTEE IT COULD GO
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE BUT WE
NEED TO LOOK FROM A BUSINESS
VIEWPOINT NONPARTISAN JUST. HOW
CAN WE BETTER SPEND THE MONEY.
AND MY ONE THING THAT IS BY
DEFAULT MEMBER I'M FO YOUR BILL
. BUT BY DEFAULT WE'RE GOING
HOUSING FIRST. RIGHT BUT WE
SHOULD BE GOING IN MY OPINION.
CLEANING UP THE DRUGS FIRST. IT
SEEMS THAT WE DON'T WANT TO.
HELP PEOPLE GET CLEAN AND SOBER
AND ALL THESE PROGRAMS WHEN I
WAS MAYOR OF MY CITY IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WE HAD EIGHTY TWO.
HOMELESS PROGRAMS SETS EIGHTY
TWO CEOS VICE PRESIDENTS CFO'S
EXCEPT HER SO MOST OF THE
HOMELESS MONEY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY BECAUSE THAT'S ALL I KNOW
WAS GOING TO INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THE HOMELESS ORGANIZATIONS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT AS WELL SO
I WILL BE A RESPECTFULLY BECAUSE
YOU ARE MY DEAR FRIEND.
ABSTAINED THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE I'LL JUST CONCLUDE BY
SAYING I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND- JUST GIVEN
THE VULNERABILITIES OF THE
COMMUNITY THE CONSTITUENCY THAT
WERE SPEAKING OF- IT'S A IT'S
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT A LOT OF
REFORMS BUT WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE REAR OF PEOPLE COMING LIST
IN THE SHORT TERM AND SO WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT A QUICK STOP- IT
DRESSES. ROUGHLY ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE- IT'S NOT EVEN
ENOUGH SO IT'S JUST ONE STEP IN
IN THE DIRECTION OF. MAKING SURE
THAT WERE- ESTABLISHING A- CATCH
BASIN AT THE SYSTEM OF MAKING
SURE THAT- NOT EVERYONE IS
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS- BE
IT A SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE COALITION ON WORKING
WITH. WITH ME AND WITH MY STAFF
ON THIS BILL- AS WELL AS MY
STAFF- MY LEAD CONSULTANT ON
WORKING ON THIS BILL AND TRYING
TO MOVE THE BALL FORWARD IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS VULNERABLE
TO VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
ADDRESSED- MEASURES THE- WITH
THAT SAID I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU. IT'S GOOD TO
AN AYE VOTE. FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWO FIVE FOUR SEVEN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION BY REYES SECOND BY BLANCA
RUBIO NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN HI THE
PAL NOT VOTING THE PELL NOT
VOTING BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH HI FRIEDMAN.
LACKEY REYES REYES HI BLANCA
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO HI THE BILL
HAS FOUR. VERY WELL IF YOU THINK
HE'S SO AB. TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PASSES TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THAT
LEAVES US. WITH THE LAST FILE
ITEM WHICH IS AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX CREATES THE RESIDENT
DESIGNATED SUCH PERSONS ACT THE
ANALYSIS REFLECTS THE AMENDMENTS
INTENDED TO CLARIFY SOME ASPECTS
OF THE BILL TODAY I'M ASKING YOU
TO VOTE ON THE BILL IN PRINT AND
THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
NEXT WEEK IN ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES. THIS
MEASURE IS A PRODUCT OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX- IN SHORES ALL
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOMES OR
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES THE
RIGHT TO IN PERSON ON SITE AND
ON SCHEDULED VISITATION FROM A
MINIMUM OF TWO RESIDENT
DESIGNATED. SUPPORT PERSONS-
DURING ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN WHICH A RESIDENTS
NORMAL VISITATION RIGHTS ARE
CURTAILED SUPPORT PERSONS
PROVIDE A CRITICAL AND OFTEN
LIFESAVING ROLE IN THE LIVES OF
RESIDENTS IN CARE FACILITY IS
SETTINGS. THEY PROVIDE AMONG
OTHER THINGS COMPANIONSHIP
COGNITIVE STIMULATION.
COMMUNICATION AND DECISION
MAKING ASSISTANCE OFTENTIMES
THEY PROVIDE ASSISTANCE WITH
DAILY LIVING TASKS SUCH AS
EATING DRESSING AND HYGIENE.
THEY PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
CONNECTION TRANSPORTATION AND
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY THE FULL
EXTENT OF THE SUPPORT WAS POORLY
UNDERSTOOD BY THE DEPARTMENT
OVERSEERS WHO AUTHORIZED
VISITATION LOCKOUTS. DURING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OR OTHER
EMERGENCY SITUATION LONG TERM
CARE RESIDENTS ARE INCREASINGLY
VULNERABLE OVERSIGHT BODIES MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO PERFORM THEIR
ORDINARY SUPERVISORY. FUNCTIONS
IN THE CURRENT PANDEMIC SUPPORT
PERSONS HAVE OFTEN BEEN BARRED
FROM VISITING AT A TIME WHEN
RESIDENTS NEEDED THEM THE MOST.
THE PANDEMIC THERE WERE A
STAGGERING NUMBER OF ALL
FACILITY LETTERS PUT OUT BY DPH
THE MAJORITY IMPACTING CARE IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES DSS
PUT OUT PROVIDER INFORMATION
NOTICES AN EXPONENTIALLY GREATER
NUMBERS AS WELL. CARE FACILITIES
WERE DEALING WITH COVERED
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS INCREASED
INFECTION PROTOCOLS STAFFING
SHORTAGES AND MORE AS NURSING
HOMES AND ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES WERE ATTEMPTING TO
FOLLOW GUIDELINES SET FORTH BY
DPH AND DSS THE IMPORTANCE OF IN
PERSON VISITATION WAS FORGOTTEN.
THE MORBIDITY ASSOCIATED WITH
COVERT NINETEEN ISOLATION IS
STILL DATA THAT REMAINS ELUSIVE
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
AUTHORIZES THE FACILITY TO ROUTE
REQUIRED AS- SUPER. INFECTION
CONTROL PROTOCOLS REQUIRED OF
CARE STAFF DURING A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND ALL
INFECTION CONTROL PROTOCOLS MUST
BE COMMUNICATED TO THE
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS
PROVISIONS SET FORTH IN AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX CANNOT BE
SUSPENDED SUPERSEDED OR MODIFIED
BY A STATE OR LOCAL ORDER. WITH
ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX ART TONY- CHICKEN
TELL REPRESENTING CANNER AND
MIGHT LEE WEISSMAN REPRESENTING
THE ESSENTIAL CARE GIVER
COALITION. THANK OU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S TONY CHICKEN
TELLEM SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. VERY EXCITED TO
TESTIFY ABOUT AB TWO FIVE FOUR
SIX- AB TWO FIVE FOUR SIX IS
ABOUT CORRECTING A MISTAKE OF A
VERY HORRIBLE MISTAKEN FOR
CLOSING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
MISTAKE TO EVER BE REPEATED. I
PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO TELL THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THE LAST TWO
YEARS HAVE BEEN THE WORST TWO
YEARS IN THE HISTORY OF LONG
TERM CARE- THE LOSSES HAVE BEEN
STAGGERING. CALCULABLE WE HAVE
WE NOT HAVE HAPPENED AT LEAST
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DEATHS OF
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOMES AND
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT WHICH SUFFERED
TREMENDOUS LOSS FROM ISOLATION
AND- THE LOSS. FROM ISOLATION IS
DIFFICULT TO CALCULATE. BUT LET
ME TELL YOU 1100% THAT IT HAS
BEEN EVERY BIT AS DEVASTATING.
AND TERRIBLE AS THE DEATHS HAVE
BEEN- WHAT MAKES THIS LOSS EVEN
MORE FRUSTRATING IS THAT IT'S
BEEN THE RESULT OF POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE-
IGNORANTLY AND MISGUIDED LEE.
FUNDAMENTALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITIES BLEW IT. THEY WERE
BOTH MYOPIC AND ENUMERATE THEY
FOCUSED ON KOBE NINETEEN
INFECTION RATES BUT PERFORMED NO
DATA ANALYSIS ON RESIDENT
OUTCOMES CONSIDERING THAT THEY
WERE DISCONNECTED FROM THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY CARED ABOUT THE
MOST AND WHO CARED ABOUT THEM
THE MOST. EPIDEMIOLOGY IS. AN
EVIDENCE AND DATA BUT WHAT WE
GOT WAS. A POLICY BASED ON
HUNCHES AND- IN A VERY NARROW
VIEW OF WHAT RESIDENT WELL BEING
AND HEALTH IS. OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
LAWMAKERS RELIED ON A TRAGICALLY
FLAWED PREMISE THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS REALLY ALL ABOUT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE PORTANTINO WELLBEING
THEN THE FIRST. HALF THEY COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN MORE WRONG SUPPORT
PERSON VISITORS PERFORM MANY OF
THE SAME SERVICES AS FACILITIES
STAFF. TO KEEP RESIDENTS ALIVE
AND TO HELP THEM GET BETTER. AND
THEY BRING THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
WELL BEING. LOVE POLICY MAKERS
MOST OF WHOM HAVE NEVER SET FOOT
IN A LONG TERM CARE FACILITY IN
A PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY. SIMPLY
HAD NO IDEA WHAT FAMILY MEMBERS
AND OTHER SUPPORT PERSONS BRING
TO RESIDENTS. WHAT THEY DIDN'T
KNOW MOSTLY BECAUSE THEY WERE
COMPLETELY IN CURIOUS ABOUT REAL
RESIDENT EXPERIENCE. WAS A
SUPPORT PERSON. THE LUXURY. I
CANNOT CONVEY TO YOU HOW AWFUL
THE LOCKOUTS HAVE BEEN FOR A
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
RESIDENTS AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO SCORES OF THEM
SPOUSES BROTHERS SISTERS AND
CHILDREN OF RESIDENTS WHO WERE
DENIED ACCESS TO SUPPORT THEIR
LOVED ONES. TO BE PRESENT TO
COMFORT THEM WHEN THEY WERE
DYING. RESIDENT AND FAMILIES
HAVE BEEN LEFT. TO WATCH DEATHS
VIA FACETIME AND ZOOM. AB TWO
FIVE FOUR SIX IS A CHANCE TO
SHOW WE CAN LEARN AND GET BETTER
OUR POLICIES WERE NOT
SUFFICIENTLY PROTECTIVE OF RESIN
ACCESS TO SUPPORT PERSONS WE
HAVE LEARNED THAT DESPITE COVERT
OR ANY OTHER PANDEMIC THERE IS
NOTHING WORSE FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY RESIDENTS. THAT TO CUT
OFF THE CARE AND LOVE THE PEOPLE
THAT SUPPORT THEM. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M BLANCA
CASTRO IN THE STATE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE AGING LONG TERM
CARE COMMITTEE- ARE LETTER FOR
THE STATE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN HAS BEEN SUBMITTED
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT. BUT I'M
HERE FOR MORE IMPORTANT REASON
WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
FOR SYSTEMIC CHANGE. AND BECAUSE
OF THAT AND BECAUSE THE PERSON
WHO WROTE THIS TESTIMONY IS NOT
ABLE TO BE HERE BECAUSE SHE
LIVES IN LOS ANGELES SHE ASKED
ME TO READ IT. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO PUT A FACE TO THE
IMPACT THAT THESE LOCKDOWNS
HOW'D. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MELODY TAYLOR STARK AND I'M VOTE
A VOTING MEMBER OF THE FORTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. I AM
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF MY
HUSBAND DR BILL STARK AND OTHERS
WHO ARE WERE AND WILL BE A LONG
TERM CARE. AN UPBEAT. PERSON
BILL WAS A RESIDENT A NURSING
HOME TO POST POLIO SYNDROME. I
COME BY THE NURSING HOME FOR MY
DAILY GOOD MORNING AND TO HUG
AND KISS MY HUSBAND. I'D COME
BACK AFTER WORK AND WE'D SPEND
THE EVENING TOGETHER AND I WAS
ALSO WITH HIM ON WEEKENDS. MARCH
THIRTEENTHTWENTY TWENTY A CALL
CAME THAT THE FACILITY WAS UNDER
MANDATED LOCKDOWN DUE TO COPE.
AS DAYS TURNED INTO MONTHS. BILL
HAD NO CONTACT WITH ME EXCEPT BY
PHONE. I TRIED ALL POSSIBLE
MEANS TO HAVE MORE CONTACT WITH
MY HUSBAND BUT EVERYTHING
INCLUDING VIDEO CHATS AND WINDOW
VISITS WERE DENIED. THE
ADMINISTRATOR TO HAVE APPROVAL
FROM CORPORATE NOR L. A. COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH. HE BECAME. BILL
BECAME INCREASINGLY DEPRESSED.
ON OUR PHONE CALLS HE'D SAY.
THIS IS NO WAY TO LIVE AND HE
WOULD CRY. HE HAD A DRASTIC
DECLINE BOTH PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH REPORTS OF THIS TO THE
FACILITY ACCOMPLISH NOTHING.
THEY PLACE BAIT BLAME AT L. A.
T. P. H. FOR BLOCKING IN PERSON
FAMILY SUPPORT AND WHEN THEY
WERE FINALLY ALLOWED IN AUGUST.
FIFTEEN MINUTE WINDOW VISITS
LIMITED TO ONE TIME WE'RE NOT
ENOUGH. DIFFERENT SEVERAL WEEKS
BEFORE HIS DEATH BILL TOLD THE
LA DAILY LOSE CORONAVIRUS VIRUS
IS NOTHING TO FOOL AROUND WITH
BUT SAID THAT THAT DIDN'T MAKE.
THAT DIDN'T MAKE BRIEFLY SEEN
HIS WIFE ONCE A MONTH OR THE
SOCIAL LIFE AGENT ANY EASIER.
I'M IN ESSENCE IN A CELL. A ROOM
I'VE GOT TV IN THE NEWSPAPERS
BUT THAT SAID I'M NOT HAPPY. ON
OCTOBER TWENTY FOURTH. TWENTY
TWENTY BILL WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
PNEUMONIA IT WAS DISCOVERED BY
ME DURING A PHONE CALL HOW COULD
I NOTICED A CHANGE IN CONDITION
OVER THE TELEPHONE WITH THE
STAFF DIDN'T. WHAT TYPE OF CARE
WAS HE RECEIVING HE WAS
HOSPITALIZED ON NOVEMBER THIRD
AND READMITTED TO THE NURSING
HOME NOVEMBER ELEVENTH. CALLS
FROM THE NURSES INDICATED HIS
HOUSE WAS HEALTH WAS RAPIDLY
DECLINING. IT WAS A DOCTOR
DYSTOPIAN NIGHTMARE. NO ONE IN
THE FACILITY ADMITTED THAT THIS
MATTER IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THEY
NOTICED NO ONE COULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY I HAD TO STAND BY
HELPLESS AS MY HUSBAND DECLINED
. AS IF THEY WERE HANDING ME A
GIFT. ON NOVEMBER EIGHTEEN THE
NURSING HOME ALLOWED ME TO
COMPASSIONATE CARE VISIT FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES. THROUGH FULL
PP. AND SIX FEET AWAY HAPPY TO
SEE ME IN PERSON. BILL SMART. M.
BLUETOOTH. AS I WAS LEAVING. I
SAW STAFF WORK THE SAME P. P. AS
I HAD COME INTO HIS ROOM TO
PROVIDE UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL
SUPPORT IT HIS WIFE FOR TWENTY
YEARS HAD TO STAY SIX FEET AWAY.
RIGHT HE WAS READMITTED TO THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS WERE FAILING. I
DID HARD MY HUSBAND ONE LAST
TIME IT WAS WHEN I CARRY HIS
ASHES FROM THE CAR TO THE CHURCH
FOR HIS FUNERAL. HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN FACILITY FAILED
BILL AND I FORMALLY REQUEST
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE MOVING
FORWARD. OTHER RESIDENTS DON'T
LOSE THEIR LIVES IS SITTING
RIGHT TO MEANINGFUL HUMAN
CONNECTION TIRELESS PRACTICE.
THAT'S ALL YOU WOULD. YES VERY
WELL. IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ERIN MANNING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX FOR MY
SISTER WHO IS CURRENTLY IN A
NURSING HOME SUFFERING FROM A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY AND FOR
MY GRANDMOTHER WHO DIED IN A
NURSING HOME BY HERSELF DUE TO
COLD IT. DINI'S BOGAN FROM
RIVERSIDE HAVE A MY MOTHER DIED
IN. A NURSING HOME FROM CLOVER
THAT WAS BROUGHT IN BY A STAFF
MEMBER. WE WATCHED HER DIE
THROUGH A FACEBOOK PORTAL. THIS
CAN NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN. CALLING
MANNING WHOSE SISTER IS
CURRENTLY IN A NURSING HOME. AND
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC WE HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING TO SEE HER AND
ALWAYS HAD TO FIGHT ACCESS AND
WE CAUGHT MULTIPLE INFECTIONS OF
THE STAFF DID NOT. AND A MOTHER
A GRANDMOTHER DIED THE NURSES
COME FROM CORPORATE. IN SUPPORT. HELLO MY NAME IS RICHARD SU
ABOUT VOLUNTEER LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN IN SAN FRANCISCO I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORTER TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX PEOPLE WHO NEED
CARE MUST NEVER AGAIN BE
ISOLATED FROM THOSE MOST
IMPORTANT IN THEIR LIVES. FAMILY
FRIENDS ANOTHER DESIGNATED
SUPPORT PERSON ARE MUCH MORE
THAN JUST VISITORS THEY'RE A
LIFELINE AND SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
FACE A BATTLE TO BE RECOGNIZED
AS SUCH. SUPPORT FOR. OVER THERE
IN DISPENSARIES BY REGULATIONS.
ONLY THE LAW CAN FIX THIS I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. HELLO MY NAME IS
NATALY WEISSMAN I AM THE CO
FOUNDER OF ESSENTIAL CARE GIVERS
COALITION. THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
CALIFORNIA ESSENTIAL FAMILY CARE
GIVERS IN OUR ORGANIZATION AS
WELL AS RESIDENTS WHO ARE THE
SPIRIT BEHIND THIS BILL. I AM
ALSO A CONSTITUENT IN DISTRICT
FIFTY AND WE- VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IF YOU. VERY
WELL. OPERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
THIS IS ONLY FOR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. WE GOT A LINE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KAREN CLINK THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
IS THERE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR HEARING EIGHTY FIVE FOUR SIX
I'M A DAUGHTER AND A DAUGHTER
WITH THE MOTHER IN MEMORY CARE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR LONG
TERM CARE. REFORM AND THIS BILL
. BILL LONG TERM CARE SYSTEM
FAILED MY MOTHER OUR FAMILY
DURING COVERT PANDEMIC AND
CONTINUES TO DO SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY SIX. YEAH
ADVOCATE. THE MASTER PLAN. ONLY
MOVES AND SEE RESPONSIBLE
NINETEEN- BUT STRONG SUPPORT AND
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE EFFORT TO
GO HOSPITAL WELL AS NURSING
CENTERS THANK YOU. LINE. EIGHTY
FOUR. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT.
MY NEED FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS DAN OPEN FIRST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
SUPPORT. ALAINA. SEVENTY FOUR.
FIVE SEVENTY FOR YOUR ONE NO
OPEN. YOUR TRUTH ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION IN COURT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX. WIND
SEVENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
BURN BOB AND I INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER IN SAN JOSE AND
THE AGENT SERVICES COLLABORATIVE
AND OUR COUNTY BOARD. TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX THANK YOU. BY.
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU THIS IS
DOCTOR MIKE WASSERMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LONG TERM CARE MEDICINE WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND HAVE
SUBMITTED A LETTER AT. SHARING A
LOT OF THE EVIDENCE BEHIND THE
REASONS FOR SUPPORTING AT THIS
THIS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
FORTY EIGHT. YES MY NAME IS
JENNY FIVE PER ANNUM IN CENTRAL
CAREGIVER FOR MY FATHER WHO WAS
ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES BECAUSE OF
CAN HER I READ UP ON THE SIDE
VISITS THE. AND I WISH THERE ALL
SOCIAL LETTER FROM THE- THAT
THEY GAVE. AND ADDS BY WAY IN
HIM IT LITERALLY HIS LIFE BUT
WHAT I SAW OF THE RESIDENTS
AROUND HIM WAS DEVASTATING THE
COMMUNITY. HAD BETTER NOT A 100%
CAPACITY. COALBED AND LISTENERS
TIME. IN LOS HALF A THEIR
RESIDENTS EITHER BY MOVING OUT
OR DYING. THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. IT THINGS
THAT I FOUND FOOD ON THE COUNTER
ABOUT SPOILED. THE NEW SAID ROOM
NO OUT TO. IT FOR THIS GO ON AND
ON AND BUT I TO AND- EVERY OTHER
PRESIDENT DESERVES THAT CARE FOR
ME AS ALL SUPPORT IT WITH YOU
RIGHT FORTY SIX THANK YOU WRAP
IT UP. THANK YOU. WHAT. NINETY
TWO. SH SH HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR
TREATS THE PALMER I'M AN MD
GERIATRICIAN AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTEEN WHICH IS
GOING TO ELECTION TODAY- I AM
ALSO A DAUGHTER OF A NURSING
HOME PATIENT- WHO DIED- JEFF
THIS BEGAN TO DIGEST WAS AS I
WAS ALLOW INTO TWO YEARS OUT.
BEING LOCKED UP AND NO ONE
NOTICED THAT SHE WASN'T EATING-
OUR- DINNER CAME HOME WOULD TEND
pHER WERE IN EATING AND WE'RE
DYING. NICOLE A PERSONAL CARE
AMERICAN FAMILIES PLEASE DO NOT
REPEAT OUR MISTAKES PLEASE DO
NOT A LOT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT WHO ARE AGES AND
IGNORANT ABOUT CONDITIONS IN
NURSING HOME TO GET.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX THANK YOU
. BY THE. SEVEN HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE THE BOND I AM THE
DAUGHTER OF. SHARE RESIDENT IN
ASSISTED LIVING THAT DIED.
MARKET JUST SHORTLY AFTER LOCKED
OUT AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
MY MOTHER WOULD NOT HAVE DIED IF
I HAD BEEN ABLE TO GET IN THERE
AND TAKE CARE OF HER THE WAY.
AIR CORPS. THE PLACE WAS SHORT
STAFF. SHE WAS OFTEN NEGLECTED.
AND THEN EXTREMELY DEPRESSED AS
A RESULT. EIGHTY TWO FIVE FOUR
SIX PLEASE VOTE YES THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
MELANIE TAYLOR STARK EVIDENCE
NEAR HEARD MY TESTIMONY THANK
YOU BONTA FOR DELIVERING IT. ON
BEHALF OF BY. THOSE WHO ARE AND
WILL BE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ALSO IN HONOR OF
MY FRIEND PAT JONES CAN'T BE ON
THIS CALL. TO GIVE. WORK FOR
THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
NURSING HOME AND DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS TO DO SO. WE ALL PART
FORTY SIX THANK YOU. BUYING ONE
HUNDRED. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA DO
GRAU AND I'M AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTEEN MY MOTHER IS A
LONG TERM CARE RESIDENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN AND I
IN SUPPORT OF. AB TWO FIVE FOUR
. I WANT TO SAY THAT. ARE
VULNERABLE FAMILY MEMBERS IN
FACILITIES NEED US TO BRING OUR
EYES AND EARS TO WHAT'S GOING ON
FOR THEM SO THAT WE CAN SPEAK
OUT PARTICULARLY FOR FOLKS WITH
DEMENTIA AND ALL. MINOR BOY YOU
CAN NOT HAVE THE COGNITIVE IN TO
SPEAK. ON AND HAVE THE- WE-
WEARING A ABLE TO KEEP P. AND BY
WHAT ROLE BE- CARE PROVIDER ARE
ACTUALLY IT UP. THANK YOU I'M
DONE LINE. NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS
NOW IF YOU FOLLOW THIS
CONSTITUENT. I'M CALLING VOICE
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. LINE
NINETY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
BERMAN RAPPAPORT WITH CARE
GIVERS FOR COMPROMISE AN
ESSENTIAL CARE GIVERS COALITION
I'M IN SUPPORT. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX WE ARE NOT VISITORS
WE ARE THEIR LIFELINE THANK YOU
. NINE FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU
HEAR ME YES. HI AND MY NAME IS
MERCEDES MAY I HAVE A LOVED ONE
MY BROTHER IN LONG TERM CARE
AND- WE GOT INTO OUR VISIT AFTER
HALF A YEAR DESPITE ALL THE
GUIDANCE THAT DON'T. WE NEED
HELP. EIGHTY TWO POINT SIX. NINE
NINE. HI MY NAME IS CHEN WITH
THE FAMILIES OF THE SPOKANE LONG
TERM CARE OP AND THE THIRD WE'RE
GOING. BUT THE- OKAY THEN THE
PART OF THE THANK. LINE SIX. HI
MY NAME IS STEVEN I'M A RED IN A
LONG TERM CARE LIST FACILITY- ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF MY RESIDENTS
HERE MY NEIGHBORS AND WHAT ABOUT
A LOT. THE PEOPLE- AND THEY
COULDN'T GET IT AND FOR THE OF
PEOPLE THAT I PROVIDE PEER
SUPPORT FOR- DURING THESE
EMERGENCY WALK INS I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY.
WHY NUMBER IT LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN MATTEO COUNTY I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX. THE POLICE SUPPORT
THANK YOU WHY NOT I KNOW TELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON DELIGHT ON BEHALF
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE OF. HI THE TRIO MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A HUNDRED AND
THREE AND IN LONG TERM CARE WHEN
HE PASSED AWAY FROM KOBE LEADING
GETS TAKEN BY THE IS FOR. TWENTY
OPERATOR WE MUST TAKE A SHORT
BREAK TO DO HOUSEKEEPING- DO I
HAVE A MOTION FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR. Q. THREE THREE ONE.
TWO ONE SEVEN FIVE ONE SIX EIGHT
FOUR AND ONE B. FIVE FIVE. OKAY
DO YOU HAVE IN THE RIVER YEAH
FOR FREE RENDON TAKEN CALENDAR
DOES AREA HI THE SYRIAN HI THE
PAL I HELLO HI PERFORMED. AT I.
RIGHT FRIEDMAN LACK. LACKEY I.
REYES I BLOOD RUBIO ARE GOING
THROUGH THE I- WELL UP ANY ELSE
IN SUPPORT. A SECURE THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THAT WAS ON TIMING. SO IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. YEAH. I SEE NO
OPPOSITION OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE AND OPERATE
OPPOSITION. IF ANYONE WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO GET SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE SEVERAL SEVERAL
ONE CITIZENS HAVE SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. WE'RE GOING
TO FIRST GO TO LINE. FIFTY SIX.
HI THIS IS KATHY BURKE WITH THE
HELP OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED ESTATE IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BETTY ARMSTRONG WITH THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL. AGAIN AND IN THE
IN OFFICE THANK YOU. LINE ONE OH
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ROCKSTAND GOLD CREEK
SIXPENCE DOT ORG AND EXECUTION
OF SMALL FAMILY TYPE SETTINGS
RESIDENTS CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND DEVELOPMENT
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABLED WE'RE
MORE OF A TWEENER WHOLEHEARTEDLY
IN AGREEMENT WITH THE OBJECTIVE.
THE BILL WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT IT RESIDENT RETURNING TO
PHILLY AND NOT HAVING THE
ABILITY TO QUARANTINE THEM TELL
. THEY GET A- I WORK WITH THAT.
YEAH YEAH THE TWENTY SECOND
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK VERY WELL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNS OR COMMENTS. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR- WHAT
WE'VE HEARD IN OUR DISTRICT SO
MANY PEOPLE WHO'VE DIED IN
NURSING HOMES MY UNCLE ONE OF
THOSE. AND TO NOT BE ABLE TO BE
THERE WILL. DIFFICULT TO GET IT
WAS IMPORTANT IS THAT. NOBODY
WAS PREPARED FOR WHAT WE WENT
THROUGH FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS. AND SO WE MAY BE
FORGIVING ABOUT THAT. LESSONS
LEARNED IN THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
THE NEXT STEP HAS TO BE WE BE WE
THIS HAS TO BE. RATIONS OR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE BETTER PROTECTED. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS I HAVE A-
COMMENT. WONDERFUL BILL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR VERY GREAT-
THERE IS AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE BUT IT'S A POSITIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE USUALLY
THEIR NEGATIVE RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S ALL YOU EVER HEAR UP HERE
. SO POSITIVE. CONSEQUENCE
BEFORE CO BID. WE INSPECTED
NURSING HOMES WE'VE MADE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
UNDER SUPERVISION OF THE STATE.
MANAGERS WE HAD THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE INSPECTORS
INSPECT PRESSES- M. THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO INSPECT A NURSING
HOME EVERY NINETY DAYS IN
REALITY IT CAME OUT EVERY
HUNDRED DAYS AND CHAIR SHARE THE
COMMITTEE ON ON FOR THIS WE HEAR
OF IT AND NOW WE'RE JUST TO READ
. BUDDY BACK IN LESS THAN EIGHTY
VOLUNTEERS TO INSPECT NURSING
HOMES SO THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS BILL IS.
DETERS WE'LL KNOW WHAT THE
CONDITION OF THE NURSING HOME IS
NOW IN THE INSURANCE BUSINESS MY%
COMPANY INSURED SOME NURSING
HOMES AND WHEN I WENT THROUGH IN
THE FIRST DAY I DID. WITH THAT
PLACE SMELL THAT MEANS THEY'RE
NOT WASH FOR THERE'S A PROBLEM.
OR THEY'RE NOT DOING THEIR FOOD
CORRECTLY I MEAN THERE'S JUST
THE SNIFF TEST. CAN TELL YOU A
LOT ABOUT A NURSING HOME IMAGINE
IF ALL THESE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE ALLOWED IN TO VISIT THEIR
LOVED ONES. THERE'S A WHOLE LOT
US TEST GOING ON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR YOU THIS IS A
BEAUTIFUL BUILT. SHALL WE CALL
THE ROLL ON IT. FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TWO FIVE FOUR SIX. MOTION IS
DO YOU PASS AND BE RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH MOTION
BY BLANCA RUBIO SECOND BY REYES
I. MISTER NAZARIAN. IT IS VERY
AND I FELT. L. I REMEMBER VAST
WHATEVER MATH HI FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I LACKEY LACKEY I REYES
. REYES I BLANCA RUBIO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE THIS I
WOULD. YOU'RE. AND WALDRON THANK
YOU. HELLO. YEAH THINK WE JUST
NEED TO GO BACK AND ADD ON TO-
ONE BILL- ASSEMBLY. GET TWENTY
FIVE YES FILE ITEM SIX TURN AT
TWENTY FIVE FORTY AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN. SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ITEM SIX AB TWO FIVE FOUR
SEVEN MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
RE REFER TO THE CAN DOWN
APPROVED. FRIEDMAN I HE. RIGHT
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.
HELLO. OKAY SHE. RIGHT NOW. OR.
YOUR AVAILABLE.
IN ORDER. AS YOU. THE. YEAH. ONE
THEY ALL THIS BUT FOR. YES.